we've now almost completed our journey
this will be it for talking about
several kinds of learning the venerable
kind that's the nearest neighbors and
decision tree or identification tree
types of learning still useful still the
right thing to do if there's no reason
not to do the simple thing then we have
the biologically inspired approaches
neural nets all kinds of problems with
local maxima and overfitting and
oscillation if you get the rate constant
too big I don't know
genetic algorithms like neural nets both
are very naive in the in their attempt
to mimic nature so maybe they work on a
class of problems they surely do each
have a class of problems which they're
good but as a general purpose first
resort don't recommend it but now the
theorists have come out and done some
things that are very remarkable and in
the end you have to say wow these are so
such powerful ideas I wonder if I wonder
if Nature has discovered them too is
there good engineering in the brain
based on good science or given the
nature of evolutions that just random
junk that isn't the best way for doing
anything who knows but today we're going
to talk about an idea I'll bet is in
there somewhere
because it's easy to implement it's
extremely powerful and what it does and
it's the essential item in anybody's
repertoire of learning mechanisms it's
also a mechanism which if you understand
only by formula you will never be able
to work the problems on the quiz that's
for sure because on the surface it looks
like it'd be very competent complicated
to simulate this approach but once you
understand how it works and looking a
little bit of the math and let it sing
songs to you it turns out to be
extremely easy so it's about it's about
letting them multiple methods work in
your behalf
so far we've been talking about using
just one method to do something and what
we're going to do now is going to look
and look to see if a crowd can be
smarter than the participants and
than the individuals in the crowd but
before we get too far down that abstract
path let me just say that the whole
works
has to do with classification and binary
classification you know am i holding a
piece of chalk in my hand or a hand
grenade
is that a cup of coffee or tea those are
binary classification problems and so
we're going to be talking today strictly
about binary classification we're not
going to be talking about finding the
right letter in the alphabet that's
written on the page that's a 26 way
choice we're talking about binary
choices so we have what we assume that
there's a set of classifiers that we can
draw on here's one H and it produces
either a minus one or a plus one so
that's how the classification is done if
it's coffee plus one if it's t minus one
if it's chalk plus one if it's
hand-grenade minus one so that's how the
classification works now too bad for us
normally the world doesn't give us very
good classifier so if we look at the
error rate of this classifier or any
other classifier and that error rate
will range from zero to one terms of the
fraction of lis for fractions of cases
got wrong on a sample set so you like
your error rate to be way down here
you're dead if it's over there but what
about in the middle what if it's a right
there just a little bit better than
flipping a coin if it's just a little
bit better than flipping a coin that's a
weak classifier
and the question is can you make a
classifier that's way over here like
they're a strong classifier by combining
several of these weak classifiers and
letting them vote so how would you do
that you might say well let us make a
big classifier capital H that works on
some sample X and as its output produces
something that depends on the sum of the
outputs of the individual classifiers so
we have h1 working on X we have h2
working on X and we have h3 also working
on X say three of them just to start us
off and now let's add those guys up and
take the sign of the output so if two
out of the three of those guys agree
then we'll get an either plus 1 or minus
1 if all three agree we'll get plus one
or minus one we're just taking the sign
output we're just taking the sign of the
sum of these guys so this means that one
guy can be wrong as long as the other
two guys are right but I think it's
easier to see how this all works if you
think of some space of samples and you
say well let's let that area here be
where h1 wrong and this area over here
is where h2 is wrong and then this over
area over here is where h3 is wrong
so if the situation is like that then
this formula always gives you the right
answers on the samples and where I stop
saying that right now because I want it
to be kind of a background thing on the
sample set we're talking about wrapping
this stuff over the sample set
later on we'll ask okay given that you
trained this thing on a sample set how
well does it do on some new examples
because we want to ask ourselves about
overfitting questions but for now we
just want to look and see if we believe
that this arrangement where each of
these guys each of these H's is
producing plus one or minus one we're
adding them up and taking the sign is
that going to give us a better result
than the than the test individually and
if they if they look like this one
draped over a sample set then it's clear
that we're going to get the right answer
every time because there's no area here
where any two of those tests are giving
us the wrong answer so the two that are
getting the right answer in this little
circle here for h1 these other two are
getting the right answers so they'll
boat it and you'll get the right answer
every time but I don't know it doesn't
have to be that simple it could look
like this there could be a situation
where this is H one wrong answer this is
H two wrong answer and this is H three
wrong answer and now the situation gets
a little bit more murky because we have
to ask ourselves whether that area with
two out of the three or three out of
three get it wrong is sufficiently big
so as to be worse than one of the
individual tests so if you look at that
Venn diagram and stare at it long enough
try some things you can say well there
is no case where this will give a worse
answer or you might end up with a
conclusion
that there are cases where we can
arrange those circles such that the
voting scheme will give an answer that's
worse than an individual test but I'm
not going to tell you the answer because
I think we'll make that a quiz question
so good idea okay so make that a quiz
question so that looks like a good idea
and we can we can sort of construct a
little algorithm that will help us pick
the pick the particular weak classifiers
to plug in here we've got a whole bag of
classifiers we got H one we got H - we
got age 55 we got a lot of we can choose
from so what we're going to do is we're
going to use the data undisturbed to
produce H one we're just going to try
all the tests on the data and see which
one gives us the smallest error rate and
that's a good guy so we're going to use
that then we're going to use the data
with the with an exaggeration of H one
errors in other words this is this is a
critical idea what we're going to do is
we're gonna we got we're going to run
this algorithm again but instead of just
looking at the number of number of
samples that are got wrong what we're
going to do is we're going to look at
the what we're going to look at a
distorted a distorted set of samples
where the ones we're not doing well on
has an exaggerated effect on the result
so we're going to weight them or
multiply them or do something so we're
going to pay more attention to the
samples on which h1 produces an error
and that's going to give us h2 and then
we're going to do it one more time
because we've got three things to go
with here and it's
the exploratory scheme this time we're
going to have an exaggeration of those
samples which simply regarding
exaggerated now we're going to
exaggerate we're going to looking for
the ones where oh we might as well look
for the ones where h1 gives us a
different answer from h2 because we want
to be on a good guy side so we can say
we're going to exaggerate those samples
for which h1 gives us a different result
from h2 that's going to give us h3 all
right so we can think of this this whole
works here as part one of a multi-part
idea
so see I don't know what might be step
two well this is a good idea then what
we've got we can easily derive from that
is a little tree looked like this and we
can say that H of X depends on H 1 H 2
and H 3 but now if that that's a good
idea and that gives us a better answer
than any of the individual tests maybe
we can make this idea a little bit
recursive and say well maybe H 1 is
actually not an atomic test but maybe
it's the vote of three other tests so we
can make a little tree structure it
looks like this so this is H 1 1 H 1 to
H 1 3 and 3 here and then this will be H
3 1 H 3 2 H 3 3 and so that's a sort of
get-out-the-vote idea where we're trying
to get a whole bunch of individual tests
into the act so the reason is I guess
the reason this wasn't discovered until
about 10 years ago was because you got
to get so many of these ducks all lined
up before the idea gets through that
long filter ideas so that's the only
idea number 2 of quite a few well next
thing we might think is well we keep
talking about these classifiers what
kind of classifiers are we talking about
I've got oh
shoot I've spent my last nickel I don't
have a coin to flip but that's what's
one classifier right as trouble that
classifier is it so it's not a weak
classifier because it gives me a 50-50
chance of being right I guess I guess
our conditions in which a coin flip is
better than a is a weak classifier if
the two outcomes are not equally
probable then a coin flip is a perfectly
good weak classifier
I don't know what we're going to do is
we're going to think in terms of a
different a different set of classifiers
and we're going to call them decision
tree when you remember decision trees
right but we're not going to have build
decision trees we're going to use
decision tree decision tree stumps so if
we have a two-dimensional space that
looks like this then a decision tree
stump is a single test it's not a
complete tree that will divide up the
samples into homogeneous groups it's
just what you can do with one test so
each each possible test is a classifier
how many tests we get out of that
twelve right yeah it doesn't look like
twelve me either but here's how you get
to twelve one decision tree tests you
can stick in there would be that test
right there and that's that would be a
complete decision tree stump but of
course you could also put in this one
that would be another decision tree
stump
now for this one on the right I could
say everything on the right is a - or I
could say everything on the right is a
plus it happen to be wrong but it's a
valid it's a valid test with a valid
outcome so that's how we double the
number of tests that we have lines for
and you know what we can even have a
kind of test out here that says that
everything is plus where everything is
wrong
so for each to mention the number of
decision tree stumps is the number of
lines I can put in times - and then I
got two dimensions here that's how I got
the twelve so there are three lines I
can have the pluses on either the left
or the right side so that's six and then
I got two dimensions that gives me 12 so
that's the decision tree stump idea and
here are the other decision tree
boundaries obviously just like that all
right so that's one way you can generate
tests a batch of tests to try out with
this with this idea of using a lot of
tests to help you get the job done you
also have a decision tree on the right
side well you don't need the question is
can you also have a test on the right
side see this is this is just a stand-in
for saying everything's plus or
everything's minus so it doesn't matter
where you put the line we on the right
side of the left side the bottom at the
top or you don't have to put the line
anywhere it's just an extra test in
addition to once you put between the
samples so it is a this whole idea of
boosting the idea the main idea of the
day does it depend on using decision
tree stumps answer is No
do not be confused you can use boosting
with any kind of classifier so why do I
use decision tree stumps today because
it makes my life easy we can look at it
we can see what it's doing but we could
put a neural bunch of neural nets in
there we could put a bunch of real
decision trees in there we could put a I
don't know a bunch of nearest neighbor
things in there the boosting idea
doesn't care I just use these decision
tree stumps because I and everybody else
use them for illustration all right so
that's we're making progress now what's
the error rate for any of these want any
of these tests and lines we drew well I
guess it will be the some error rate is
equal to the sum of 1 over n that's the
total number of points number of samples
summed over the cases where we are wrong
all right
so G you know we're going to kind of
work on combining some of these ideas
and we get this notion of exaggeration
at some stage and what we're doing here
we're going to want to have to be able
to exaggerate the effect of some errors
relative to other errors so one thing we
can do is we can we can assume or we can
stipulate or we can assert that each of
these samples has a weight associated
with it that's w1 this is w2 and that's
w3 and in the beginning there's no
reason to suppose that any one of these
is more or less important or any of the
other so in the beginning W sub I at
time step 1 is equal to 1 over n so the
error is just adding up the number of
samples that were got wrong and that
will be the fraction of samples that you
didn't get right and that will
the error rate so what we don't what we
want to do is we want to say instead of
using this is the error rate for all
time what we want to do is we want to
move that over and say that the error
rate is equal to the sum over the things
you got wrong in the current step times
the weights of those that were got wrong
so in step one everything's got the same
weight doesn't matter but if we find a
way to change the weights going
downstream so as to for example highly
exaggerated that third sample then w3
will go up relative to w1 and w2 now one
thing we want to be sure of is no matter
how we adjust the weights that the sum
of the weights over the whole space is
equal to one so in other words we want
to choose the weights so that they
emphasize some of the samples but we
also want to put a constraint on the
weights such that all of them added
together is something to one and we'll
say that that enforces a distribution
the distribution is a sum as a set of
weights that sum to one well that's
that's just a just a nice idea so we're
making a little progress we we've got
this idea that we can add some plus
minus one classifiers together you get a
better classifier we got some idea about
how to do that occurs to us and maybe we
want to get a lot of classifiers into
the act somehow or another and maybe we
want to just think about using decision
tree stumps so as to kind of ground our
thinking about all this stuff
so next step is to say well how actually
should we combine this stuff and people
find in the Lich or libraries full of
papers that do stuff like that and that
was state of the art for quite a few
years but then people began to say well
maybe we can build up this classifier H
and X in multiple steps and get a lot of
classifiers into the act so maybe we can
say that the classifier is the sign the
sign of H you know that's the one we
pick first
that's the classifier we pick first
that's a that's looking at samples and
then we got h2 and then we got h3 and
then we got how many other other
classifiers we might want or how many
classifiers we might need in order to
correctly classify everything in our
sample set so people began to think
about whether there might be a way of an
algorithm that would develop a
classifier that way one step at a time
that's why I put that that's why I put
that step number in the exponent because
we're picking this one at first then
we're expanding it to have two and then
we're expand have three and so on and
each of those individual classifiers are
separately looking at the sample but of
course it would be natural to suppose
that just adding things up wouldn't be
enough and it's not so it isn't too hard
to invent the next idea which is to
modify this thing just a little bit by
doing what it looks almost like a
scoring polynomial doesn't so what would
we do to tart this up a little bit come
again do well
somewhere out there someone's murmuring
add weights excellent good idea so what
we're going to do is we're going to have
alphas associated with each of these
classifiers we're going to determine if
somebody can build that kind of formula
to do the job so maybe I ought to modify
this gold star idea before it get too
far downstream and we're going to say
we're not going to treat everybody in a
crowd equally we're going to weight some
of the opinions more than others and by
the way they're all going to make errors
in different parts of the space so maybe
it's not the wisdom of even a weighted
crowd but a crowd of experts each of
which is good at different parts of the
space so in hell we got this this
formula and there are a few things that
one can say sort of sort of turnout and
but but first let's let's write down
sort of algorithm for what this ought to
look like before I went on a space I
think I'll exploit the right-hand board
here put the overall algorithm right
here so we're going to start out by
letting the weights at all the weights
at time one be equal to one over N
that's just saying that they're all
equal in the beginning and they're equal
to 1 over N and n is the number of
samples and then when I got that I want
to compute alpha somehow
now let's see no I don't want to do that
I want to pick I want to pick a test I
want to pick a classifier that minimizes
the error rate then M eyeses error at
time T and that's going to be at time T
and we're going to come back in here
that's why we put a time or step-index
in there so once we've picked a
classifier that produces an error rate
then we can use the error rate to
determine a alpha so I don't want to put
the alpha over here I'll be sort of a
byproduct of picking that test and with
all that stuff in hand maybe that will
be enough to calculate WT plus one so
we're going to use that classifier that
we just picked to get some revised
weights and then we're going to go
around that loop until this classifier
produces a perfect set of conclusions on
all the sample data so that's going to
be our overall strategy maybe we've got
if we're going to number these things
that's the fourth big idea and this this
arrangement here is a fifth big idea
then we got the sixth big idea and the
sixth big idea says this suppose
that the weight on the ice sample at
time t plus one is equal to the weight
at time t of that same on that same
sample divided by some normalizing
factor times e to the minus alpha at
time t times h at at time t times some
function y which is a function of x but
not a function of time and you say where
the discs come from and the answer is it
did not spring from the heart of a
mathematician in the first 10 minutes
that they looked at this problem in fact
when i asked you very well how this
worked he said well he was thinking
about this on the couch every saturday
for about a year and his wife was
getting pretty sore but he finally found
it and saved their marriage so where
does stuff like this come from really it
comes from knowing a lot of mathematics
and seeing a lot of situations and
knowing that something like this might
be mathematically convenient something
like this might be mathematically
convenient but we got to let us see we
got it back up and let it sing to us
what's why how we saw why last time the
sort of support vector machines that's
just a function that's plus 1 or minus 1
depending on whether the output ought to
be plus 1 or minus 1 so if this guy is
giving the correct answer and the
correct answer is plus then this guy
will be plus 1/2 because it so it always
gives you the correct answer
so in that case where this guy's giving
you the right answer
these will have the same sign so that
would be a plus 1 combination
on the other hand if that guy's giving
the wrong answer you're going to get a
-1 out of that combination so it's true
even if the radiator should be - right
so if the right answer should be minus
and this is plus then this will be minus
1 and the whole combination will give
you minus 1 again in other words the the
Y just flips the sign if you got the
wrong answer no matter whether the wrong
answer is plus 1 or minus 1 these alphas
shoot those are the same alphas that are
in this formula up here somehow and in
that Z what's that for well if you just
look at the previous weights and its
exponential function to produce these
w's for the next generation that's not
going to be a distribution because they
won't sum up to 1 so what this thing
here this Z is that's a sort of
normalizer and that makes that makes
that whole combination of new weights
add up to 1 so it's whatever you've got
by adding up all of those guys and and
then dividing by that number well
I don't know now there's some it turns
out that we're going to do or rather
we're going to imagine that somebody has
done the same sort of thing we did to
support vector machines we're going to
find a way to minimize the error and
here we're going to minimize is the
error produced by that whole thing up
there and for we're going to minimize
the error of that entire expression as
we go along and what we discover when we
do the appropriate differentiations and
stuff you know that's what we do in
calculus what we discover is that we get
minimum error for whole thing if alpha
is equal to 1 minus the error rate at
time T divided by the error rate at time
T but let's take the logarithm of that
and multiply by 1/2 and that's what
Shapiro was struggling to find but I
haven't quite got it right and so let me
add this in separate chunks so we don't
get confused about this
it's a bound on that expression up there
it's a bound on the error rate produced
by that expression so interestingly
enough this means that this means that
the error rate can actually go up as you
move as you add terms to this formula
all you know is that the error rate is
going to be bounded by an exponentially
decaying function so it's eventually
guaranteed to converge on zero so it's a
minimal error bound it turns out to be
exponential
well there it is we're done would you
like to see a demonstration yeah okay
because you know you look at that and
say well how could anything like that
possibly work and the answer is
surprisingly enough here's what happens
there's a simple little example so
that's the first test chosen that greens
are pluses and the Reds are minuses so
it's still like it's still got to still
got an error still going to air boom
there are two steps that now has we can
look in the upper right-hand corner we
see it's used three classifiers and we
see that one of those classifiers says
that everybody belongs to a particular
class three different weights and the
error rate has converged to zero so
let's look at a couple of other ones
here's a the one I use for debugging
this thing let that run see how fast is
Luton and converges to getting all the
samples right very fast here's another
one now this week this is when we gave
on an exam two years back first test
oh I'd let it run so got everything it
Centennial right let's take that through
step at a time
there's the first one second one is to
get a lot of errors about the rare rates
dropping then flattened flattened that
goes to zero cool they think you say to
me well who cares about that stuff let's
try something more interesting there's
one now that was pretty fast too well
they're not too many samples here so I
don't know we can try this so there's an
array of pluses and minuses oh you can
see how that error rate is kind of
bounded by an exponential so in a bottom
graph you've got the the number of
classifiers involved and that goes up to
a total eventually of ten you can sort
of see how positive or negative each of
the classifiers is added is by looking
at this particular tab and this just
shows how they evolve over time but a
progress thing here is the most
interesting and now you say to me well
how did the machine do that and it's all
right here we use an alpha that looks
like this and that allows us to compute
the new weights as soon as we got a
preliminary calculation we got to find a
Z that does the normalization and we
sure better bring our calculator because
we've got first of all to calculate the
error rate then we got to take its
logarithm divided by 2 plug it into that
formula take the exponent and then that
gives us the new weight and that's how
the program works
and if you try that I guarantee you will
flunk the exam now I don't care about my
computer
I really don't it it's a slave and it
can calculate these logarithms and
Exponential's till it turns blue and I
don't care cause I've got four corners
or something and who cares might as well
do this sit around just burnin up heat
you don't want to do that so what you
want to do is you want to you want to
know how to do this sort of thing more
expeditiously so we're going to have to
let them do math kind of sing to us a
little bit with a view toward finding a
better ways of doing that sort of thing
so let's let's do that and we're going
to run out of space here before long so
let me let me reclaim as much of this
board as I can so what I'm going to do
is I'm going to say well now that we've
got this formula for alpha that release
alpha T to the error then I can plug
that into this formula up here number
six and what I'll get is that the weight
at T plus one is equal to the weight at
T divided by that normalizing factor
multiplied times something that depends
on whether it's categorized correctly or
not that's what that Y's in there for
right so we got a logarithm here and we
got a sign flipper up there in terms of
@h of x and y combination so if the sign
of that whole thing at minus alpha and
that y each combination turns out to be
negative then what you're going to have
to flip the numerator and denominator
here in this logarithm right and oh by
the way since we got a half out here
that turns out to be the square root of
that term inside the logarithm right so
when we carefully do that what we
discover is that it depends on whether
it's the right thing or not but what it
turns out to be is something like a
multiplier of the square root better be
careful here square root of what well
let's see what we have to be careful so
let's suppose that this is four things
that we get correct so if it's if we get
it correct then we're going to get the
same sign out of H of X and why we've
got a minus sign out there so we're
going to flip the flip the numerator and
denominator so we're going to get the
square root of e of T over 1 minus
epsilon T if it's correct if it's wrong
it'll just be the flip of that so it'll
be the square root of 1 minus the error
rate over the error rate everybody with
me on that I think that's right if it's
a if it's wrong I'll have to hang myself
and wear a paper bag or my head like I
did last year but let's see if we can
make this go right correctly this time
so now we've got this guy here we've got
everything plugged in all right and we
know that now this is Z ought to be
selected so that it's equal to the sum
of this guy multiplied by these things
as appropriate for whether it's correct
or not
because we want in the end for all these
WS to add up to 1 so let's see what they
add up to without without the Z there so
what we know is that they must be it
must be the case that if we add over the
correct ones we get the square root of
the error rate over 1 minus the error
rate of the W T plus 1 w t sorry Plus
now we got the sum of 1 minus the error
rate over the error rate times the sum
of the WI at time T for raw
so that's that's the Sun that's what we
get if we added all these up without the
Z so since everything has to add up to 1
then Z ought to be equal to this sum
right and that looks pretty horrible
until we realize that if we add these
guys up over the weights that are wrong
that is the error rate that this is this
is e so therefore Z is equal to the
square root of the error rate times 1
minus the error rate that's the
contribution of this term and now let's
see what is the what is the sum of the
weights over the ones that are correct
well that that must be 1 minus the error
rate Oh
so this thing gives you the same term
the same the same result as this one so
Z is equal to 2 times that and that's a
good thing now we are getting somewhere
because now it becomes a little bit
easier to write some things down oh
we're way past this so let's let's get
rid of this and now we can put some
things together let me point out what
I'm putting together I've got an
expression for Z right here and I got an
expression for the new W's here so let's
put those together and say that w of t
plus 1 is equal to w of t i guess we're
going to divide that by 2 and then we
got this square root times that
expression so if we take that correct
one
and and and / that one then the ISA teak
cancel out and I get 1 over 1 minus the
error rate that's if it's correct and if
it's not correct then it's WT over to
working through the math one over
epsilon if wrong do we feel like we're
making any progress no we don't because
we're not we have a let it sink to us
enough yet so I want to draw your
attention to what amateur Rocklin what
happens to rot amateur rock climbers
when they're sort of halfway up a
difficult cliff
they usually belaid sometimes they're
not if they're not they're scared to
death and every once in a while there is
they're just about to fall they find
some little tiny hole to stick a
fingernail in and that keeps them from
falling
that's called a thank God hole so what
I'm about to introduce is the analog of
those little places where you can stick
your fingernail in
it's the thank God hole for dealing with
boosting problems alright so what
happens if I add all these WI up for the
ones that the classifier produces a
correct answer on well it'll be 1 over 2
& 1 over 1 minus epsilon times the sum
of the W sub T for which the answer was
correct what's this some oh my god it's
1 minus Epsilon
so what I've just discovered is that if
I sum the new w's over and correct those
samples for which I got a correct answer
it's equal to 1/2 and guess what that
means that if I sum them over wrong
that's equal to 1/2 as well so that
means that I take all the weights for
which I got the right answer with the
previous test and now those weights will
add up to something and you get two
weights for the next generation all I
have to do is scale them so that they
will have this was not noticed by the
people who developed this stuff this was
noticed by Luis Ortiz who is a 603 4
instructor a few years ago the sum of
those weights is going to be a scaled
version of what they were before so you
take all the weights for which this new
classifier this one you selected to give
you the minimum weight on the reweighed
and stuff you take the ones that it
gives it correct answer for and you take
all those weights and you just scale
them so they add up to 1/2 so do you
have to compute any logarithms no do you
have to compute any Exponential's no do
you have to calculate Z no if you have
to calculate alpha to get the new
weights no I'll have to do a scale
that's a pretty good thank God hole so
let's thank God hole number 1
now for thank God hole number two we
need to go back and think about the fact
that we're going to give you problems in
all probability that involve decision
tree stumps and there are a lot of
decision tree stumps that you might have
to pick from so we need to thank God
hole for deciding how to deal with out
oh where could I find some room how
about right here suppose you've got a
space that looks like this I'm just
making this up at random so how many I
see 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 how many
tests do I have to consider in that
dimension 11 it's 1 plus the number of
samples that would be horrible I don't
know do I have to actually calculate
this one how could that possibly be
better than that one it's got one more
thing wrong so this one that one that
one makes sense the other one doesn't
make sense so in the end no test that
lies between two correctly classified
samples will ever be any good so that
one's a good guy and that one's a good
guy and this one's a bad guy a bad guy
bad guy bad guy bad guy bad guy bad guy
bad guy so the actual number of tests
you got is three and likewise in the
other dimension well I haven't drawn it
so well here but can this test be a good
one know that one note because you
actually I better look over here and
write and see what I've got before you
draw too many conclusions let's leave it
with this cause I don't want to think
too hard about what's going on the other
dimension but the idea
is that very few of those tests actually
matter now you say to me there's one
last thing what about overfitting as all
this does is drape a solution over the
samples and like you know support vector
machines overfit neural nets overfit
decisions identification trees overfit
guess what this doesn't seem to overfit
that's an experimental result for which
the literature is confused with respect
to providing an explanation so this
stuff is trying on all sorts of problems
like handwriting recognition
understanding speech all sorts of stuff
uses boosting and unlike other methods
for some reason as yet imperfectly
understood it doesn't seem to overfit
but in the end leaving no stone unturned
at 6:03 for every time we do this we do
some additional experiments so here's a
sample that I'll leave you with here's a
situation in which we have a 10
dimensional space we've made a fake
distribution and then we put in that box
outlier that was just put into the space
at random so it can be viewed as an
error point so now what we're going to
do is we're going to see what happens
when we run that guy and sure enough in
13 steps and 17 steps it finds a
solution but maybe it's over fit that
little guy who's an error well one thing
you can do is you can say well all of
these classifiers are dividing the space
up into chunks and we can compute the
size of the space occupied by any sample
so one thing we can do alas I'll have to
get up at new demonstration one thing we
can do now that this guy's over here we
can switch the volume tab and watch how
the volume occupied by that error point
evolves as we solve the problem so look
what happens this is of course randomly
generated I'm counting on this working
never failed before so
it originally starts out as occupied 26%
of the total volume and ends up
occupying one point four times ten to
the minus third percent of the volume so
what tends to happen is that these
decision tree stumps tend to wrap
themselves so tightly around the air
points there's no room for overfitting
because nothing else will fit in that
same volume so that's why I think that
this thing tends to produce solutions
which don't over fit so in conclusion
this is magic you always want to use it
it will work with any kind of speed of
classifiers you want and you should
understand it very thoroughly because
this if anything is useful in their
subject was in the in the dimension of
learning this is it
you